combining scalable vector graphics with
css animation
is one of the most powerful techniques
that web designers have at their
disposal to stand out from the
competition
just look at all the amazing animated
duotone icons on the stripe homepage
or this looping animated explainer
sequence on the gatsby homepage
you don't need to be an expert designer
animator or developer to create things
like this
oh that was easy in today's tutorial
you'll build two things an animated icon
the user can interact with and a looping
animated sequence
all of which are powered by just svg and
css
and in the process you'll learn seven
cool techniques that have helped me with
vector graphics on the web over the
years
if you're new here like and subscribe
sadly half the people that watch my
content
aren't actually subscribed yet first of
all what is a scalable vector graphic
well what it isn't is a raster image
like a png or jpeg image that you might
take on your phone
those formats represent an image with a
grid of pixels and that means the
resolution
is dependent on the number of pixels in
the image to get a higher resolution
image
you need a bigger matrix with more
pixels in it in contrast
a vector image uses a totally different
approach that's based on geometry and
math instead of static pixels
if you open an svg file in your editor
you'll notice it looks exactly like html
markup
the svg tag has an attribute called view
box that defines a grid
then any graphics that are computed
inside that grid can be scaled up to any
size
because you're just multiplying the math
in that grid by the image resolution
now inside the svg tags we have a bunch
of different elements
like rect circle and polygon to draw
basic shapes
the shapes have different attributes to
define their xy coordinates and size
then you have the path element which is
the most powerful element in an svg
because it's like having access to an
imaginary pen where you can define any
sequence of lines and curves
now it's good to know what's inside an
svg but you should rarely need to write
the actual graphics code by hand
instead you should be having a graphic
designer do that in a design tool like
figma illustrator or inkscape all of
which can export vector graphics to the
svg format
now once a graphic has been drawn there
are some cool things you can do to the
code by integrating css for styling and
javascript for interaction
and we'll take a hands-on look at that
now by building an animated svg icon the
only thing you really need to follow
along with this project
is an html file and a design tool like
figma that can export svg
you can also find the full source code
on github or follow along with the
article on fireship io
i'm on the stripe homepage and i see
this little animated triangle icon
and what i want to do is reverse
engineer it if we open up chrome dev
tools
we can then hit command p and then
search for animations
to bring up the animations tab this is a
really awesome little
feature that will record all of the
animations on the page
then give you a breakdown of the
keyframes and which elements they affect
you can pause the animation and slow it
down then when you click on one of them
it will take you to that element in the
dom it's really useful to inspect other
websites that have impressive animations
going on
you can see how their svg code is
structured and you can even copy and
paste it if you want to mess with it in
your own editor a useful piece of
information i've gathered by inspecting
the code
is that it's not actually two triangles
but four triangles it's just that two of
them are hidden
off canvas to make the animation
possible the first step in recreating
something like this
is to draw the graphics and to handle
that we'll use a free tool on the web
called figma
inside the app we'll create a frame
which is equivalent to the view box in
the svg code
we'll make the canvas a 120 units wide
by a hundred units high
when designing we'll think in pixels and
i'd recommend drawing on the smallest
frame possible that'll make it easier to
align things and make your graphics
pixel perfect
from there we'll use the polygon tool to
draw three triangles
we'll give one of the triangles a
different color and then decrease the
opacity on all of them making them
somewhat transparent you'll notice on
the layers panel here that figma is
automatically creating layer names for
us but if you have layers that you're
going to style with css
or animate i'd recommend giving them
their own custom names
like in this case i've named my
triangles dark 1 dark 2
and light 1. and when figma exports it
to svg
it will use those names as ids on the
element allowing us to easily target it
in the code with a css selector
now another very important tip if you
want to create duotone icons
is to group your elements together based
on color when you create a group
it's actually going to create a g
element in the svg code
which is kind of like a div in html it's
just a container for grouping
and styling elements together so we'll
select the two dark elements
group them then give the group itself a
name of dark group
and then do the same thing for the light
group now to recreate the animation
we'll want to position the light
triangle first then the dark one
triangle
after it now the second dark triangle
will actually be positioned
off the screen when the animation starts
but we'll handle that with css
so for right now we'll just position it
directly on top of the light triangle
that takes care of our design
now we just need to export it to svg
which we can do in figma by selecting
the frame
then clicking on the export button down
here on the bottom right corner make
sure that it's svg format
then click on the menu to also include
the id attributes on the export that'll
make the file a little bit larger but
much easier to work with with css
animation
oh and also uncheck the box to show the
frame fill color
and the export now go ahead and open the
file up in vs code
you should see markup with an svg that
has a view box of 120 by 100
then you'll see group elements that have
ids based on what we assigned in figma
and finally inside the groups you'll
find the actual paths that draw the
graphics
now we could use this svg file with an
html image tag
but we can also just declare this markup
directly in the html which opens up the
door to custom styling
and animation go ahead and copy the code
then create an html file
and add the svg graphic to the body what
i want to show you now
is how to make this a themeable duotone
icon
if you open up this html page in a
browser you should notice the icon there
that looks identical to what you
designed in figma if we take a closer
look at one of the path elements you'll
notice that there's a fill
attribute that is coded to a certain
color that's fine if the color never
changes
but inline styles like this are hard to
override so let's go ahead and delete
the fill colors
from the svg code if you open up the
html page you'll notice that the
triangles are invisible
we can change that by opening up a style
tag and then we'll target the root
element where we can define css
variables
we have a dark color and a light color
then we can assign those variables to
groups in our svg
by targeting their id the dark group is
filled with a dark color and the light
group filled with the light color
and now our icon is easily themable the
next question
is how do we animate this icon when the
user hovers over it
first we'll need to select the three
triangles that we want to animate based
on their ids
we can then tell them to animate
automatically using the transition
property
this tells css to animate all properties
on the element
over a duration of one second with a
timing function of ease
and now all we have to do is change the
styling on the elements and they will
animate automatically
if you remember earlier our graphic has
a dark triangle
on top of the light triangle but we want
to move that entirely off the screen
before the animation starts and we can
do that by setting its transform
translate x value to negative one
hundred percent
which will move it over to the left now
from there we'll target the hover event
on the svg itself then we'll target the
styling of each triangle
individually the light triangle will
just move over to the right a little bit
the dark triangle will also move over to
the right but it will also change its
opacity to zero
to fade out and then finally we have the
second dark triangle which is currently
invisible off the screen
we can bring it back into the screen by
setting the translate x back to zero
and now if we go back to the demo and
hover over the icon you should see the
animation transition back and forth
that's a good start but another cool
thing we can do is target events on the
svg
using javascript what we'll do next is
change the styling of the button
dynamically every time that it's clicked
to handle that we'll open up a script
tag just before the closing body tag
you can handle events on the svg itself
or individual shapes within the svg
we'll go ahead and select our triangles
group using document getelementbyid then
we can define a function
that will be called on its click event
the function contains an array of colors
then we'll define another function here
to randomly select a color from that
array
we can then change the css variables
that we defined earlier
by targeting the document element style
css text
and that will change our dark and light
color variables to random values
a nice little bonus here is that the
color change will also be animated
because we already have that transition
animation
on the element targeting all properties
and now we get a nice little translation
between colors whenever we click on the
icon
icons are cool but what if we wanted a
looping animation that just runs in the
background
without the need for the user to
interact with it something like that
will require keyframe animations in the
demo notice how we have an outline of a
phone
then some skeleton text pops in from the
bottom after that
a few icons drop in in a staggered
motion from the top
now i'm not going to draw this graphic
from scratch and figma it's really just
a set of a bunch of simple shapes that
i'm sure you can figure out and of
course you can find the code for this
graphic on github
what i do want to show you though is
that we have separate groups for the
phone the skeleton text
and the bolt icons when the icons drop
in they'll be staggered
so we have those numbered based on the
order in which they should appear
go ahead and export the graphic and then
bring it into your html just like we did
in the previous example
then open up a style tag and the first
group that we'll want to target
is the skeleton text it should fade
upwards from the bottom
so we'll create a keyframes animation
called fade in up
we can then apply that animation to the
group in the svg using the animation
property
with the name over a duration of one
second
now the way a keyframes animation works
is it starts with a certain set of
properties
then animates to a different set of
properties over that duration which in
this case would be one second from
is the beginning of the animation which
will start with an opacity of zero
and a transform that will move the group
slightly down the y
axis by twenty percent then we can
define properties for
two which is the end of the animation at
that point the group should have an
opacity of 1
and be translated back to its original
position and that's all it takes to
build a simple keyframe animation
that can fade in the skeleton text now
we'll tackle the more complex
requirement
of building a staggered keyframe
animation we need to target each icon
in the bulk group individually and then
we'll define a keyframes animation
called drop in
that will drop those icons in from the
top initially they'll have an opacity of
zero
then we'll assign the animation to run
for eight seconds with an easing
function
in addition we'll define the animation
direction as forwards
which tells it to use the last value in
the keyframe after the animation ends
in addition if you want the animation to
loop you can add the infinite value
which tells it to run continuously on a
loop
now when you have a staggered animation
running on a loop you really need to
think carefully about your keyframes
you need to think of the animation in
its entirety which in this case
is a full 8 seconds and design the
keyframes accordingly
in this example we don't want the
elements to appear for the first twenty
percent of the animation
then between twenty and thirty percent
they'll drop in from the top
then normally they would start fading
out for the remaining seventy percent of
the animation
but in this case we want them to hold
that position so we'll also keep those
values consistent
through 100 so that takes care of the
drop in animation
but now the question becomes how do we
stagger it there are a few different
ways you might approach this
but i think the cleanest way is to
define inline css variables
directly in the svg itself the inline
variables will have higher priority
which means we can access them
in our style sheet in the svg code we'll
want to find
each bolt group and on that group we'll
apply a style
that has a css variable named order
which represents the order in which they
should appear
we'll go ahead and do that for all five
icons in the svg
then we can come back to our main style
sheet and add the animation delay
property
the cool thing about css variables is
that we can use them with calc
to dynamically calculate a value for the
delay just multiply the order value by
200 milliseconds
to have each icon drop in 200
milliseconds after the other
and you now have an animated svg that
will impress your friends and get you a
job and land you customers by standing
out from the competition i'm going to go
ahead and wrap things up there
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and consider becoming a pro
member at fireship io thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one